we are just 35 minutes the finishing
line is inside the rocker says he's held
back the order to help the kitchen means
is there even further behind with the
service the bottom line is I forgot the
ticket ya didn't hold anything back
forgot the [ __ ] and he's come here
and he said of being a man and Tate said
to me with balls
look chef this happened it can happen to
anyone this come to me and said to me
and lied to me thinking I'm stupid since
tina's in this [ __ ] I mean big time all
because of Rocco but I have to say that
my respect tonight because I'm if that
was Li in that situation 10 years ago I
would've flipped my lid big time and
pickled the Bulls of Rocco turn them
into [ __ ] blah blah something knows
cooked his heart out tonight he's only
just made it to the end of service but
for my diners his simple Sicilian food
has been outstanding what was a menu
tonight
no the menu was linguine beef linguine
beef 25 times we had the passion the
soul of food but we didn't match it with
a service when you have a table of six
we've got to get that six in and we
waited 92 minutes before you realized
that that table was forgotten that's not
good enough
Rocco look back on it do it again and
I'll kill you
alright today I want yeah well done
thank you Thank You chef classy
oh so intense oh my god
it was like the biggest rush in your
life it was just amazing I don't know
what went on with the front hours I
could kill him
well we held it together
I'm so stupid smile on my face I'm so
happy I am so proud